et pour en parler nous sommes avec
vincent maréchal spécialiste en
virologie bonsoir vincent spéciale merci
beaucoup d'être avec nous tout d'abord
je voulais m'arrêter quelques secondes
un traitement disponible avant l'été
nous dit mike pence vous y croyez alors
on a il faut quand même savoir qu'on a
aujourd'hui toute une liste de molécules
qui existe dans l'est dans nos
pharmacies pour d'autres applications et
qu' il ya un certain nombre d'essais
cliniques sont lancés un peu partout
dans le monde pour tester ces molécules
et peut-être qu'avec un peu de chance
dans le lot on trouvera une molécule qui
sera utilisable au rejet pas de détails
sur l'annoncé américaine
mais il ya des essais très actif pour
essayer de tester des molécules oui
alors 212 cas en france
quatre décès emmanuel macron qui nous
dit que ça peut durer cette phase en
tout cas des semaines voire des mois
quelle est votre réaction de professeurs
de médecine alors pas de médecine de
virologie mais voilà alors bas ce qu'on
essaye de faire aujourd'hui c'est de
regarder ce qui se passe ailleurs
alors les informations de chinon qu'à
une réduction du nombre de cas déclarés
chaque jour alors est ce que ça tient
aux mesures qui ont été prises par la
chine est ce que ça tient compte de deux
modifications de comportement etc
le saura bientôt c'est une épidémie qui
aurait enfin ça c'est sûr alors savoir
quand ça c'est une question à laquelle
on peut pas répondre aujourd'hui on est
aujourd'hui dans une phase où le virus
circule sur le territoire par groupe et
on sent que les groupes sont plus en
plus diffus donc le virus va circuler
assez librement ce qui veut dire qu'on
prend des mesures
heure par heure qui évoluent en fonction
de la situation alors quelle est la
conduite à tenir parce qu'on en est
restée aux voilà l'invitation à rester à
la maison quand on revient de zones à
risques un voile à singapour la chine
l'italie
mais alors quid des
des régions de l'oise du morbihan ça
veut dire que je ne devrais pas
totalement la question comme ça ce qui
est important que les gens comprennent
c'est qu'il ya une gradation dans la
réponse à une gradation dans la
situation quand on a dit aux gens qui
venaient de zones à risque de rester à
la maison c'était parce qu'on voulait au
maximum dans la première phase dans le
stade un c'est de limiter l'arrivée du
virus sur le territoire
la phase 2 qui visait à laisser les
joueurs à la maison c'était pour éviter
de laisser le virus circule et on voit
que le virus circule donc la phase 1
s'est terminé la phase 2 on allait bien
engagée et on commence à réfléchir à la
phase iii au stade 3 du plan alors le
stade iii et est un stade qui est plus
complexe dans les mesures qui seront
prises dont il ya des mesures qui sont
d'abord des mesures de sanitaires très
importante donc l'idée c'est que dans
les hôpitaux on concentre les cas les
plus graves ceux qui nécessitent une
prise en charge médicale
on va solliciter pour vraiment mobilisé
l'ensemble des personnels de santé pour
faire en sorte qu'en ville les cas les
moins graves puissent être pris en
charge par les médecins et par les
structures plus des structures plus
légères et puis un troisième point qui
est important c'est de protéger faut pas
l'oublier les gens les plus sensibles un
des points importants c'est que cela le
taux de mortalité est le taux de gravité
augmente avec l'âge
donc il va falloir mettre en place des
barrières pour empêcher notamment les
gens dans les ehpad d'être contaminés et
donc ça veut dire aujourd'hui que pour
vous les mesures édictées par le
gouvernement ne seront plus tellement
adapté d'une certaine façon le soin un
presque dépassé
non elles sont pas les gens réagissent
au fur et à mesure de l'évolution de
l'épidémie on peut pas mettre en place
des dispositifs on est on est partis
faut bien comprendre qu'on est parti de
mesures qui étaient des mesures
individuelles et qu'on arrive à un stade
où les mesures vont devenir collective
alors je pense que les mesures qui vont
être données voix de différentes natures
et on va aussi demander aux gens
beaucoup plus de responsabilisation dans
les entreprises dans les structures
identifier les postes des postes les
plus à risque les postes qu'on doit
maintenir les activités qu'on doit
maintenir et puis dire aux gens dont
l'activité peut être fait à domicile par
exemple de rester à la maison
ça va s'organiser mais chacun se
responsabilise aussi pour vous il ya une
clairement une surréaction peut-être une
forme de psychose dans le pays alors sur
réaction c'est toujours un terme
nationale la réaction dans une situation
comme ça c'est normal qu'une réaction
une surréaction ça c'est difficile
alors il ya la surréaction en termes de
mesure où en termes d'individus ce n'est
pas tout à fait la même ce que je vois
c'est des gens très angoissée
et finalement quand on discute un peu
avec eux qui se désengage cantons rpt
explique par exemple aux parents que les
enfants sont pas les premières cibles et
bien des angoisses un petit peu les
parents quand on explique que les
personnes les plus à l'est plus à risque
sont des gens qui ont plus de 60 70 ans
quand on voit les cas les plus graves
des noms mais bien sûr donc non mais ça
permet de concentrer l'attention sur les
gens les plus sensibles voilà a fortiori
s'ils ont des caractères de 6 à des
facteurs de comorbidité diabète
hypertension il faut faire attention aux
gens les plus fragiles aujourd'hui et
donc quelle est la conduite à tenir pour
justement alors qu'ils ont dû abandonner
ses grands parents à titre individuel
voilà à titre individuel limitée
peut-être les contacts avec les
personnes les plus âgées ou les plus
fragiles donc ces personnages sont
peut-être des personnes qui doivent
prendre un peu plus de précautions
éviter les contacts sociaux maximum
après je pense qu'il faut aussi être
raisonnable on va pas arrêter de vivre
il faut continuer à trouver un modus
vivendi et rendre compatibles les
activités qu'on doit conduire à avoir
une vie sociale avec effectivement un
certain nombre de réserves l'on prend
l'habitude de ne plus serrer la main de
pas se faire la bise
bon bah voilà en revanche moi je prends
le métro et le rer tous les matins on
voit que la situation n'a pas changé
effectivement les jardins conféra
perturbé que ça dans le métro on va voir
qu'au tournant dans ce stade trois
justement quelles mesures vont être
prises sur les rassemblements la taille
des rassemblements sur la circulation
sur les transports l'approvisionnement
ces questions là vous êtes reposé et on
va vraiment ils réprouvent
progressivement vous disiez toute
épidémie a une fin qu'est ce qui selon
vous pourrez mettre fin celle ci il ya
plusieurs hypothèses aujourd'hui
on a fait beaucoup de parallèles avec le
virus de la grippe faut savoir qu'à
d'autres coronavirus qui sont beaucoup
plus bénins qui circulent en france
chaque année cela nous préoccupe pas
beaucoup et on sait que ce sont des
virus qui aiment le froid qui aime
l'humilité qui sont dans la transmission
est plus facile divers auxquels première
hypothèse qui consiste à dire et sans
envie depuis très longtemps de la sortie
de l'hiver changement de climat
ça devrait régresser maintenant
comparaison n'est pas raison et le
corona virus a sa vie propre
donc on va surveiller surtout et vous
reviendrez nous voir on l'espère merci
vincent maréchal professeur en virologie
merci à vous dont quelques saisons